es wird große teleskop der welt und die
europäische südsternwarte eso erhofft
sich mit ihm außerirdischer aufzuspüren
jetzt wurde der bau des european
extremely large telescope vlt offiziell
gestartet und schon 2024 server teleskop
in betrieb gehen warum die europäische
südsternwarte ein teleskop in chile in
der trockensten wüste der welt baut und
warum damit außerirdische gefunden
werden wollen jetzt endlich zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
es ist ein wirklich unwirtlicher ort die
atacama wüste
ich war jetzt schon dort und es wirklich
wie auf dem mond in dieser trockensten
wüste der welt in chile hinzu kommt die
höhe bis auf 4500 meter bin ich dort
hochgefahren und es gibt durch diese
absoluten extrembedingungen kaum leben
in dieser region für die europäische
südsternwarte eso ist es aber die beste
region um teleskope zu betreiben
die trockene atmosphäre geringe
luftströmung und weit entfernte städte
die die beobachtung durch
lichtverschmutzung stören würden
machen diese region ideal für teleskope
und schiene hat die evo hier schon
zahlreiche teleskope bauen lassen
die revolutionäre erkenntnisse liefert
haben so lieferte das very large
telescope vlt das erste bild eines
exoplaneten die bewegungsmuster von
15.000 sonnenähnlichen sternen in der
nähe unserer sonne wurden bestimmt es
wurden beweise für die existenz die
supermassereichen schwarzen loches
sagittarius stern im zentrum unserer
milchstraße gefunden und vieles vieles
mehr
die atacama wüste ist eben der ideale
ort für ein teleskop und durch moderne
technologien und schlicht die größe wird
das neue european extremely large
telescope das hubble weltraumteleskop in
der auflösung um der 16-fache über
treffend um das 16-fache wahnsinn sogar
luftströmungen in der atmosphäre kann
das irt ausgleichen es verfügt über
6.000 sogenannte aktuatoren die
atmosphärische turbulenzen 1000 mal pro
sekunde korrigieren können
da werden atemberaubende bilder die das
teleskop liefern wird und wir werden
vollkommen neue erkenntnisse sammeln
können so ausgestattet bietet es einen
riesigen fortschritt gegenüber habe
zudem wird es auch über zahlreiche
unterschiedliche instrumente verfügen um
das universum zu untersuchen
durch eine spezielle konstruktion kann
das eingefangene licht je nach bedarf
auf die jeweiligen instrumente gelenkt
werden und dabei spielt die suche nach
außerirdischen hier wieder eine
besondere rolle epics der exoplanet
imager soll speziell exoplaneten
aufleben untersuchen
mit seinen spektrografen solle das lied
von exoplaneten analysieren und so
feststellen wie die atmosphären der
exoplaneten jeweils zusammengesetzt sind
die forscherinnen und forscher der eso
erhoffen sich darüber erkenntnisse ob es
leben auf dem planeten gibt für josef
tim de zeeuw ist das teleskop ein
riesiger sprung und erhofft sich dass
damit leben in all entdeckt so langsam
verliere ich den überblick wer wo wie
überall außerirdisches leben entdecken
will deshalb gibt es demnächst hier mal
eine übersicht darüber was alles geplant
ist da wer dieses video und alle anderen
nicht verpassen will
er drückt mir am besten hier ein abo
aufs auge und nicht den auf die glocke
vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit allen videos wie
bisher zum thema außerirdische gemacht
habe es werden immer mehr
in einer playlist also drauf klicken und
ihr könnt sie alle hintereinander sind
und hier sage ich ohne jeden klick bis
dann bleibt dran